I want to take up in volume 4 and begin with June 13, 1901. If you want to put a heading
on this, it's no cross, no crown. After a long silence on the part of my adorable Jesus,
at the most a few things about the scourges he wants to pour. This morning, as I was
oppressed and tired because of my hard position, especially because of the continuous privations
to which I am often subjected, I saw Jesus for short instances, and he told me, "My
daughter, crosses and tribulations are the bread of eternal beatitude." In other words,
you can decide yourself what height you want in heaven by the crosses and tribulations
that you accept from the Lord. I understood, Louisa said, that as we suffer more, more
abundant and more enjoyable will be the bread that will nourish us in the celestial dwelling,
so no cross, no crown. It's actually that simple. And the bigger the cross, the bigger
the crown. If you're size 10 on earth, you get a size 10 cross and you get a size 10
crown. If you are size 20 on earth, you get a size 20 crown. Now a size 20 crown doesn't
fit a size 10 head. So you get the crown that actually suits you that you've actually worked
towards. So the greater the deposit we receive in the future glory. So in Romans 8, Paul
tells us that what God gives us in eternal glory is out of all proportion to anything
that we can suffer in this life. Also in 2 Corinthians 5, I think it is, St. Paul says
that we actually work on earth to make our own dwelling in heaven. And you can make it
with wood or straw, or you can make it with silver and gold, you can make a hot or you
can make a palace, depending on your own decision.
So June 18, 1901, I have a VIP on this one. And this is that we are obliged to give glory
to God in everything we are.
As I was in my usual state, I saw my sweet Jesus for a little, and I began my laments
about my poor state of his privations and about a sort of tiredness, both physical and
moral, as if I felt my poor nature crushed. Now if the Lord doesn't actually sustain
her, she cannot stay alive because her life is absolutely abnormal.
So as if I felt my poor nature being crushed and failing me in all its parts, and then
after I said all of this to Jesus, he told me, "My daughter, don't be concerned about
your feeling you're falling apart. I mean, it's incredible. Don't you know that everything
must be sacrificed for me, not only in the soul, but also in the body?" So now we have
a new picture for Louisa. She is a living sacrifice of praise and thanksgiving to God,
a daily sacrifice of praise.
And Jesus continued, "And that from the tiniest little particles of your being, I demand
my glory. And then don't you know that from the state of union one passes on to another
state that of consummation, two Thessalonians, one, twelve." So the state of union is like
we get married and the state of consummation is that the marriage is consummated in this
oneness of the two.
So the state of consummation is a higher state than just the state of union. It's true that
I'm not coming as usual so as to chastise the people.
But I use this also for your own prophet, which is not only that of keeping you united
to me, but of consuming you for love of me. Now, it's only volume four and Louisa still
doesn't understand that the privation of Jesus is a very big part of her sacrifice.
She doesn't accept it all that well and every now and then she's able to offer it out of
love for him. But most of the time she just suffers it.
After all Jesus said, "Do you not have great reason? You do not have great reason to afflict
yourself. First, because when you see me, it's always from your interior that you see
me. And this is the sure sign that I am with you.
And also because not one day has yet come in which you can say that you have not seen
me perfectly." Now, that is an absolutely extraordinary statement of Jesus. No other
saint apart from our blessed mother could say that.
After this Jesus' voice assumed a sweeter and more benign tone and he added, "My daughter,
I recommend to you very, very much that you let not even the slightest act which is not
patience, resignation, sweetness, sameness." That's the firmness, the immutability he's
talking about, tranquility, and everything come out of yourself. Now, this applies most
particularly to the time of the privations when she goes into a complete crisis. Otherwise,
he said, "You would dishonor me." So he's demanding complete heroism from her.
In these early volumes, it looks as if that heroism is almost impossible. But when you
get up beyond volume 20, it's perfectly normal for her. So he is working on her bit by bit.
That is Philippians 1, 6. The work I have begun in you, I will complete." And he does
complete this work in her in a very wonderful way. So he said, "Don't let anything that's
not patience or resignation or sweetness and so on come out of you. Otherwise, you would
dishonor me." And it would be the same as it would happen to a king who lived in a palace
which was well adorned inside, but on the outside it could be seen full of cracks stained
and about to collapse. Would people not say, "What? A king lives in this place?" And
yet such an ugly configuration can be seen on the outside as to make one fear even to
draw near it. Now, what Jesus is saying is, "Our faults, which are obvious to other
people, are real blocks to them accepting the fact that God is working in us." Even
Matthew Ghande is famous for having said that he loved Christ, but he couldn't bear Christians.
He said, "Now one of them is like him." And so we can really put people off. So Jesus
continues, who knows what a king, oh yeah, who knows what a king he must be like. Would
this not be a dishonor to the king? Now think that if anything which is not virtue comes
out of view, they, that is everybody else, would say the same about me. And it would
also dishonor the Lord because if the Lord puts up with anything, then the moral standards
go down. As we see in the church today, because the priests are not holding up a high moral
standard. And I who live inside of you would remain dishonored, Jesus said. So June the
30th 1901, these are signs by which you will know that you have grace, therefore put a
VIP on this one as well. Louisa said, "As I was in my usual state, my most sweet Jesus
made himself seen for a short time, all transfused in me. Now my book has a capital M there and
it should be a small M because he's talking about Louisa. And he told me, "My daughter,
do you want to know what the signs are to know whether a soul possesses my grace?"
Now Jesus said in volume two, "I am grace." Okay. So whether we possess the presence of
God or not. And Louisa said, "Lord, as your most holy goodness pleases." And he replied,
"Well, the first sign." So put in number one here, is to see whether the soul possesses
my grace, is that in anything that belongs to God, which she may hear or see externally,
she feels a sweetness, a gentleness fully divine in her interior, which is not comparable
to anything human or terrestrial. It's the same as to a mother who recognizes the fruit
of her womb in the person of her son, even from his breath, his voice, and she delights
with joy. Or as two intimate female friends, who in conversing together, manifest the
same sentiments in clinicians' joys, afflictions to each other. And since each one finds her
own things engraved in the other, they feel such pleasure in them, such joy, and take
them to heart so much that they cannot detach themselves. In the same way, the interior
grace which resides in the soul on seeing externally the fruit of her womb, that is
unrecognizing herself in those things which form her very existence, corresponds with
them and makes the soul experience such joy and sweetness that one is unable to express
it. Now, the examples that Jesus gives here are very interesting. First of all, to recognize
that you're in the state of grace, many people are not sufficiently recollected or attentive
to really know how they're feeling as to whether it would be grace or not. That would take
a great deal of recollection. But it would be normal for someone like Louisa who's sitting
there in the bed giving all her attention to the Lord. And then the first example he
gives is of a mother recognizing even the breath or smell or anything of her child.
And then he gives an example that you're not expecting, and that is two intimate female
friends. Now, one of the things that you find when you look at the history of the church
is that saints don't come by themselves, saints usually come in clusters. And we have
some amazing, let me call them couples, but I don't mean that sexually, I mean that the
friendship is between a man and a woman, and they spur one another on to sanctity. If you
take Francis and Clare in the 11th century, if you take Francis de Sales and Jane de Chantal,
just to give you two examples out of many, it's usually that what Jesus here is giving
friendship between two women. Friendship between two women can actually be very deep and they
can be very, very close spiritually. And if you find such a friend, it is an amazing
grace. And you should really appreciate it because they both of them spur each other
on to sanctity. So the second sign that Jesus speaks about is that the words of the soul
who possess grace are peaceful and they have the effect of casting peace into others. Now,
you see, the God of peace is the God of grace, same person. So Jesus gives the sign of peace
so very often as the sign of his presence. He is the prince of peace. He brings peace.
He only operates within us in peace. And when the grace is deep within us, put Philippians
for seven that we have the peace that passes all understanding and guards our hearts and
our minds in Christ Jesus. So if the person claiming to be living in grace doesn't show
that there is peace inside of them and manifest peace to others, then you know that their claim
isn't true. And Jesus said so much so that the same thing said by one who does not possess
grace, make no impression and they bring no peace. While if they're said by the other
one who possesses grace, they operate in a marvelous way and bring peace back to others.
I remember hearing a priest speak about a retreat, a priest's retreat in Rome some years
ago. And Mother Trees of Calcutta was invited to speak to them. And she came out on the
stage and she spoke for approximately five, maybe seven or eight minutes. And he said
she didn't say anything that any the rest of us couldn't say. But he said the only person
in the entire retreat that left a lasting impression was herself. And here you have
the effect of somebody speaking from a very deep personal relationship with God and communicating
that grace and peace to others. So what she was communicating wasn't just her words. She
was communicating the presence and glory and peace of God to them. And I remember this
priest was telling me this about six months later. And he said the impression she made
on them was very profound. So we come to the next paragraph. Moreover Jesus said, grace
strips the soul of everything and makes of her humanity a veil in which to remain covered.
So that means that grace means that God is hidden in us in our humanity. And it's a bit
like the the bread that is the external part of the consecrated host and it's hiding the
presence of Jesus in the Eucharist. So a person in grace becomes a living host. Okay. So let
me read it again. Grace strips the soul of everything. That is everything that is not
of God and makes of her humanity a veil with which to remain covered in such a way that
as the veil is torn, one finds paradise in the soul who possesses her. So it's no wonder
that true humility, obedience and the like are found in that soul because there's nothing
left of her. That means the earthy muddy stuff. There's nothing left of her but a simple
veil. And one can see with clarity how it is all grace that acts within her and keeps
all the virtues in order for her and make her remain in continuous attitude towards God.
So Jesus is describing a soul that's completely open to God all the time and open to the
imporings of God's presence in God's grace. It's a very good description of Louisa herself.
So July the 5th 1901, Jesus is the Alpha and the Omega, the beginning and the end. As I
was concerned about the state of my soul, all of a sudden my adorable Jesus came and said
to me, my daughter do not be concerned for I alone am the beginning, the means and the
end of all your desires. With these words, I camped myself in Jesus. May everything be
for the glory of God. So I want to give you John 14, 6, Revelation 1, 8 and Revelation
21, 6. So we come to July the 16th 1901. The beginning of evil in man is the distance
between the love of Jesus and human love. After various days of privation, this morning
Jesus dained to come transporting me outside of myself. Now as I was present to him, I
could see many people and the evil of the present generation. So that's Amos 3, 7 and
Isaiah 64, 10. The Lord always tells his prophets first. So it's when Louisa goes into an outer
body experience, there she sees clearly and she sees what God sees and she comes back
with this prophetic message because as Jeremiah, when he spoke to one of the false prophets
said, have you been in the Council of God? So these outer body experiences mean that
Louisa is in the Council of God. And that's a huge thing if you know your Old Testament.
And in the Council of God, God reveals what is happening on the earth to the person who
is present to him. And as far as Jeremiah, the prophet is concerned, that is the sign
of authenticity of a prophet that you've been in the presence of God. So Louisa said,
when I was in the presence of blessed Jesus, I could see many people and the evil of the
present generation. So that's pre World War one. And of course that evil is the communism
and Marxist, atheism and materialism and rationalism and humanism and modernism and everything that
was condemned by Popiah's intent. My adorable Jesus looked at them with compassion and
turned to me and he said, my daughter, do you want to know where the evil of man began?
The beginning of it is as soon as he knows himself. That is, as soon as he begins to
acquire reason, man says to himself, I am something. I am an important person. Now this
is very important and we'll explain to you why Jesus asks of us in the divine will spirituality
to accept our nothingness, which is way beyond humility and to place our nothingness at
his disposal, because it's only from that nothing that he can truly work. If you think
of Blessed Mother's Magnificat in Luke chapter one, she said that the Almighty had regard
for his lowly maiden. Now she was the most blessed of all creatures and if anybody could
be tempted to call herself somebody, it was her. But this reminds me of a story, not a
story of an incident that happened to me during my teaching years in Africa. I was doing a
religion class and for some reason we got around to asking the girls what would they like to
become and they said various things and then one little girl at the back put her hand up
and she said, I want to become a very important somebody. And I said to her, you know, you've
spoken the truth. Everybody wants to become a very important somebody to somebody. And
if the somebody you want to become important to is the Lord, then you will become great.
But if you want to become an important somebody in your own right, you're going to give yourself
terrible trouble on this earth. So this business, as soon as we acquire human reason, we say,
I am something or I am important. And this is the beginning of pride, which is independence
of God. And of course, the world tells you to lean on yourself and sell yourself and
all the rest of it. And believing themselves to be something, they move away from me, Jesus
said, they don't trust me who am the all. And they draw all their confidence and strength
from themselves. So I want to give you Proverbs three verses five to nine, which tells you
my son, lean not on your own understanding, lean upon the greatness of God and the wisdom
of God. And this is the mistake that the world continuously makes. From this, it happens that
they even lose every good beginning. And by losing the good beginning, what will the end
be? In other words, if they go wrong at a very early age, then their lives could go
very seriously, criminally wrong. We know that if you plant a tree or a shrub and something
goes wrong in the very early stages, you're not looking forward to a great shrub or a
great tree, you're going to look forward to trouble. Imagine yourself, my daughter, Jesus
says, moreover, by moving away from me, who contains every good, what good can man hope
for since he is a sea of evil. Now, this is the Lord speaking, this isn't me, I'm reading
this. He says that we are a sea of evil. Without me, he said, everything is corruption, misery
and without a shadow of true good. And this is the way the present society is. He says
in 1901, it was 100% worse now. So I want to give you John 15 five without me, you can
do nothing, Jesus says. Louisa responded on hearing this, I felt such affliction that
I am unable to express it. But Jesus wanting to cheer me transported me somewhere else.
And as I found myself alone with my beloved Jesus, I said to him, tell me, do you love
me? I think this is a scream. It's it's his duty to say to us, do you love me? We cannot
say it to him. I mean, have we forgotten Jeremiah 31, 3, I have loved you with an everlasting
love and I am constant in my affection for you. God's love never changes. You also have
him. Oh, I've forgotten the number of the Sam now. Oh yeah, Sam 145 verse 17, God only
ever acts out of love because God is love. And so his only motivation is love. Even when
he sends us chastisements, the motivation is love. He wants to cure us. He wants to save
us. He wants to bring us to heaven. So asking Jesus if he loves us, I think is absolutely
extraordinary. Jesus simply said yes. And Louisa said, but I'm not content with yes alone,
but I would like it to be explained better how much you love me. He loves us infinitely.
Why would she even ask? And he said, my love for you is so great that not only has it
no beginning, it is no end. That's your Jeremiah 31, 3. In these few words, you can understand
how great, strong, constant is my love for you. I want to also give you John 15, nine,
as the father has loved me, that is infinitely, absolutely, eternally, unconditionally, sacrificially.
So I love you. So Louisa considered all this for a little while. And then she said she
could see an abyss of distance between her own love and his. All confused, she said, Lord,
what a difference between my love and yours, naturally, because his is infinite, and it's
eternal and ours is finite. And we can't trust it. Not only does mine have a beginning, but
as for the past, I see some voids in my soul of not having love to you. And Jesus all compassion
for me said, my beloved, there cannot be conformity between the love of the creator who is infinite
and that of a creature who is finite. Put a VIP on this now. However, today, I want to tell you
something which will be of great consolation for you, and which you have never yet understood.
Know that each soul during the whole course of her life is obliged to love me constantly
with no interval. Our Pentecatechism told us that we were created to know him, to love him,
and to serve him throughout the whole of our lives, and to be with him forever.
So he said, and no intervals. And if the soul does not love me always, she leaves as many voids
in her soul for as many days, hours, or minutes in which she has neglected to love me. Now,
unfortunately, these voids can be seen in heaven. Heaven can see that we're a bit like a colander.
There's lots of holes in us. But no one will be able to enter heaven if he has not filled
these voids. I want you to underline that in green, white, and gold. We cannot enter heaven
unless these voids are filled. So you can see why Jesus tells us in later volumes
that nine out of every 10 souls go to purgatory. And one will only be able to fill them by loving
me twice as much for the rest of his life. And if he does not arrive at doing this,
he will fill them by dint of fire in purgatory. Now, what you're seeing here is that heaven does
not permit of any imperfections. Heaven does not accept a work that's not complete. Heaven does
not accept a mission that has not been finished. And so when we get tired of religion and get switched
off and don't want to do anything, we're simply building up a long purgatory for ourselves.
Now, Jesus says to Louisa, when you are deprived of me, the privation of the beloved
makes love double. And by this, you come to fill the voids that were present in your soul.
So Jesus tells her that the pain she experiences in the privations enable her to do the reparation
that is actually required. Now, the problem is the rest of us don't have these experiences with the
Lord. And so we have to do something to fill these voids ourselves. After this, Louisa said to him,
my sweet good, let me come with you to heaven. And if you don't want it forever, at least for a
little while, now she asks him to allow her to visit heaven. Please, I pray you make me content.
And he told me, don't you know that in order to enter that blessed dwelling, the soul must be
completely transformed in me in such a way that she must appear as another Christ. Now, this whole
section, you need to give it a heading. And it is revelation about entering heaven, the conditions
under which we can enter heaven. And we're not talking about sins. And we're not talking about
sinners. We're talking about so-called good people and people who think they're living a
vibrant spiritual life. Jesus said, we can't get into heaven unless we are like him. Only other
Christ can go there. Otherwise, what impression would you make in the midst of the other blessed
in heaven? I want to give you one John three versus one to three. You yourself would be ashamed of
being with them. And that's the very reason why souls go to purgatory. They realize I'm now ready
to be here at all. Louisa said, it's true that I'm very dissimilar from you. But if you want to,
you could make me similar. Louisa doesn't give up, as you know, whenever she's in an argument with
him, she just doesn't give up. And so to content me, he enclosed me completely within himself in such
a way that I could no longer see myself but Jesus, Colossians 1, 27. But in this way, we actually
rose towards heaven. Everything is through him, with him, and in him. We can do nothing by ourselves,
John 15, 5. So she could only rise to heaven, through him, with him, and in him. And as we
reached a certain point, we found ourselves before an indescribable light. I want to give you one
Timothy 614, where St. Paul says that the Lord lives in this indescribable light. This is something
that none of us can comprehend. That light, of course, is God, 1 John 1, 5. And the light is also
the divine will, who is God. Before that light, one experienced new life, unusual joy, never before
felt how happy I was. Even more, it seemed to me that I was in the fullness of all happiness,
because as Jesus will reveal later on in these writings, the divine will is the source of all
happiness. But as we advanced before the light, I suddenly felt much concern. I would have liked
to praise him and to thank him, but not knowing what to say, I recited three glory bees and Jesus
responded along. But as soon as I finished, like a flash I found myself in the miserable prison of
my body, our Lord, he said, "How come so little has my happiness lasted?" Of course, he couldn't
take her any further, because she wasn't dead. This was only a preview. It seems that the clay of
this body of mine is too hard, as it takes so much to be shattered and it prevents my soul from moving
out of this miserable earth. Now that's two Corinthians, five, verses one to ten. But I hope that some
vehement blow may cause it to be not only shattered but pulverized, then since I would no longer have
a home to be able to stay in, you would have compassion for me and would receive me forever
into the celestial dwelling. So that's your Psalm 63, my heart and my soul and my entire being cry
out for you. So July the 20th, 1901, how sweet the voice of the soul is for Jesus. Okay, so we're
talking about the voice of the soul. As I was in my usual state, my adorable Jesus was not coming.
Then after struggling and almost losing the hope of seeing him again, all of a sudden he came and
he told me, "My daughter, your voice is sweet to me, like the voice of the mother is sweet to a
little bird." After she has left him to go in search of food with which to nourish him as she
comes back, what does the little bird do on hearing her voice? He feels sweetness and makes
feast. And after the mother has fed him, he huddles all up and hides under the maternal wing to
warm himself and to be freed from the intemperances of the air. That's Luke 1334,
where Jesus says he hides us under his wings like a hen.
Oh, how dear and pleasing it is for the little bird, this remaining under the maternal wing.
So you are for me. Remember in volume two, Jesus asked Louisa to be another mother for him on the
earth. You are the wing that warms me and shelters me and defends me and allows me to take a safe
rest. Now what he means by warms, shelters, defends and allows him to take rest, is that she makes
reparation for others. She is prepared to suffer the crucifixion in order to pay some of the debt
of the human race so that chastisements will be mitigated. And therefore the Lord can find rest
in her that she loves her neighbor as herself. Having said this, he disappeared and I remained
all confused and full of shame, knowing myself is so bad. But obedience wanted to increase my
confusion wanting me to write this. May the most holy will of God be always done.
July the 23rd 1901, Jesus speaks about his will and about love. Now you hear me saying over and over
again that the summary of the 36 volumes is divine will and love. As I was with many doubts about
my state on coming, my adorable Jesus told me, daughter do not fear. What I recommend to you is
that you remain always conformed to my will because when the divine will is in the soul,
neither the diabolical nor the human will have the strength to enter the soul to make fun of her.
Now he's telling us, Jesus is telling us that the only way that we can be spiritually safe
is in the divine will, safe from ourselves and safe from the demons. After this, Louisa said,
I seem to see him crucified and since the Lord had shared with me not only his pains but some
sufferings of another person he added, this is true love. To destroy oneself in order to give
life to others. Now what he means by destroy oneself is to allow suffering to come to yourself
in order to relieve others either to heal them or to bring them to spiritual conversion
or salvation if it's the moment of their death. So to destroy oneself in order to give life to
others, to take upon oneself the evils of others and to give me one's own goods. So there's the
Pelican image, the Pelican damages herself in order to get blood to feed her little ones.
So July the 27th 1901, we have doubts on the part of the Confessor and Jesus answers them.
Since the Confessor had raised some doubts, when Blessed Jesus came, I saw the Confessor with him
and he was saying to him, my working is always leaning on the truth. That is John 14, 6, I am the
way the truth and the life. And even though many times it appears obscure under enigmas,
however, one cannot help saying that it is the truth. And even though the person does not understand
my way of working with clarity, this doesn't destroy the truth. On the contrary, it makes one
understand much better that it is a divine way of working, not a human way. So I want to give you
Isaiah 55 verses 8 to 10. My ways are not your ways. My thoughts are as different from your thoughts
as the heavens are from the earth. In fact, since the soul is finite,
she cannot embrace and understand the infinite. At the most, she can understand and embrace a few
glimmers. As for example, the many things said by me in Scripture and my way of working in the
saints, has this perhaps been understood by all with clarity? Oh, how many things are left obscured
and in the midst of enigma. And yet how many minds of the erudite and the learned have tired
themselves in interpreting them? And what have they understood? One can say absolutely nothing
compared to what is left to be known. You see, the learned and the erudite can only
break into these mysteries insofar as they too are spiritual and that they're allowing God to do
this in their own lives. If they're not doing that, then they're merely dealing with intellectual
thoughts and ideas and therefore they are extremely limited in their ability to understand this.
You'll find that in one Corinthians chapter one. I can't remember the verses now,
but St. Paul says that where are the philosophers now? Where are the wise men now that the foolishness
of the cross has made them all look stupid? Okay? And so if they're only dealing with human philosophy
and human thinking, there's no way they can deal with the supernatural, no way at all.
But Jesus says, does this prejudice the truth? Not at all. On the contrary, it makes it shine even
more. Therefore, your eye must be kept on whether there is true virtue and whether in everything it
can be felt that truth is present. Now notice true virtue and truth in terms of teaching. True and truth.
Even though sometimes the truths are obscured, we know this ourselves in reading the volumes of
Louisa. Some of the things in the higher volumes, you just don't get it the first second or third
time you read it. You have to move on spiritually and then you get it. As for the rest, one must
remain tranquil and in holy peace. Having said this, he disappeared and Louisa said, I returned to myself.
Here now in July the 30th 1901, we're talking about pride and humility,
offerly essential things in the spiritual life. And the whole Bible speaks about pride and humility.
So I'm not going to give you too many references because I'd have to give it them all.
As I was in my usual state, Louisa said, blessed Jesus transported me outside of myself into the
midst of people. Oh, what blindness. Oh dear, I have to give you Isaiah 69 where when Isaiah saw the
Lord in his glory in the temple, he suddenly realized that the people were so blind that, you know,
they couldn't see they're so deaf they couldn't hear. They were so dumb they couldn't speak because
they had hardened their hearts and turned against the Lord, causing the blindness. You also have
John chapter nine and verses 40 and 41, Jesus had healed a man from
being blind from birth. As far as we know, the man had no eye sockets and Jesus actually created
eyes for him. And at the end of the whole process, the Pharisees and the scribes who were the leaders
said, we're not blind surely. Jesus said, if you were, I could heal you. But since you claim to see,
I could do nothing. Okay. So there are none so blind as those who refuse to see. And this is
one of the problems that Jesus had all the time with the leaders of Israel. They absolutely refused
to see. So Louisa says, what blindness? Now, when society deteriorates, you're dealing with spiritual
blindness. And this is describing our society perfectly. Almost all were blind and a few had
short sight. Only very few appeared like the sun and in the midst of the stars with extremely sharp
sight. And they're usually the saints, all intent on the divine sun. And this sight was
conceded to them because it was fixed in the light of the word, humanate, my goodness, what a word,
the word incarnate, we say. Okay. All compassion, Jesus told me, my daughter, how pride has ruined
the world. It's the first and the greatest of the deadly sins, because it blocks us off from God.
It has reached the point of destroying that small light of reason which all carry with them
from birth. You see, as society deteriorates and people go deeper and deeper into spiritual
blindness, they become more and more irrational. No, however, that the virtue which most exalts
God is humility. Our lady said that in her Magnificat in Luke 1, verses 46 to 55. And the virtue which
most exalts God, the which most exalts the creature before God and men is humility. And again,
you have the Magnificat that all generations will call me blessed. Having said this, he disappeared.
So I want to give you Matthew 2312. In Matthew 23, Jesus gives his terrible indictment against
the scribes and Pharisees. It's because of their pride and their arrogance and their
total spiritual blindness and hardness of heart. I want to give you 1 Peter 5, 6.
And I want to give you James 4, 6. So Louisa said that Jesus came back later, all panting and
afflicted and said, "My daughter, three terrible chastisements are about to happen." And then he
disappeared like a flash without giving me any time to tell him one word. Okay. So August the 3rd,
1901. I have a VIP on this. The soul who possesses grace has authority over hell,
has authority over human beings, and has authority over God himself. So authority over hell is Luke
10, verses 18 to 20. And over God himself is Matthew 18, verses 19 to 20.
This morning, my adorable Jesus was not coming. Then after much waiting, the virgin mother came,
bringing him almost by force, but Jesus would escape. Then the most holy virgin told me,
"My daughter, do not become tired of asking for him. Rather be unfortunate because this
escaping of his is a sign that he wants to send some chastisement, and therefore he escapes the
sight of his beloved ones." So here you have Blessed Mother explaining again to Louisa that
Jesus' absence is to do with the fact that he is chastising.
"You, however," Blessed Mother said, "do not stop because the soul who possesses grace,"
now this is the Blessed Mother speaking. And we should listen to mothers, you know.
"You, however, do not stop because the soul who possesses grace has authority over hell."
That means we can command the demons over human beings and over God himself. In fact,
since grace is part of God himself, as the soul possesses it,
does she perhaps not have the power over that which she possesses? That's incredible.
Our Blessed Mother knew about that power because it was the power of the fullness of grace that
she had that made her intercession for the incarnation actually happen she actually brought it about,
power over God.
Louisa continues, "Then after much resistance forced by the Queen Mother and importune by me,
Jesus came, but with an imposing serious appearance such the one wouldn't dare to speak."
Now notice the authority he has that he has this kind of appearance even Louisa who loves them to
distraction has fear. I did not know what to do to make him break that appearance so imposing.
I thought I would come out speaking nonsense saying to him, "My sweet God, let us love each other."
If we ourselves do not love each other, who else can love us? And if you are not content with my
love, who will ever be able to content you? Okay, very wonderful thing to say there because
Louisa is aware of the very great height of her love and so she says, "Look, if someone who loves
you as much as I do can't get through, nobody will get through." She's very much aware of the fact
that others love at a very lower level. And so she said, "Please, give me a sure sign that you
are content with my love. Otherwise, I will faint. I will die." But who can say all the nonsense I
spoke? I believe it's better to move on. However, it seemed that with this, I was able to break
that imposing air of his and he told me, "Only when your love will surpass the river of the
iniquities of man, then will I be content with your love." So think of increasing your love, where I
will be more content with you. This is totally amazing. He says that he'll only be content with
her love if it surpasses all the sins of humanity. That's absolutely unbelievable. And so he said,
"Think of increasing your love. How on earth could you increase your love?" The only thing you can do
is enter into the divine will and you take Jesus' own divine love and with his own divine love,
love him with that. That's the only way you can do it. There is no other.
So I want to give you August 5, 1901. Mortification is the site of the soul. So volumes one to four
are the foundation volumes of this whole spirituality. And the Lord doesn't want us to forget that
mortification and self-denial are part of the whole scene. As I was in my usual state, my blessed
Jesus was delaying incoming. I felt I was dying for the pain of his privation when all of a sudden
he came and he told me. My daughter, just as the eyes are the sight of the body, so mortification
is the sight of the soul. Therefore, mortification can be called eyes of the soul. We need to remember
that, don't we? August 6, 1901, the love of the blessed is a property of God, which the love of the
pilgrim soul is like a property which is in the act of acquiring. Now here again, we're speaking
about love and Jesus is going to say that the love of the blessed is already acquired property
for him, but he's looking for more territory by going around us looking for love from us.
This morning after I received communion, my adorable Jesus made himself seen all in suffering
and offended such as Torah's compassion. I classed him all to myself and I said to him,
my sweet good, how lovable and desirable you are, how can people not love you? Even worse,
they offend you. By loving you, one finds everything and loving you contains all goods,
while not loving you means that all good escapes. And yet, who loves you?
"Please," she said, "my dearest treasure, put aside the offenses of humans and let us pour
ourselves out and loving each other for a little." And then Jesus called the whole celestial court
to be a spectator of our love, and he said, "the love of the whole of heaven would not render me
satisfied and content. If yours were not there, united with it." In other words,
I know Louisa is a very special case and everything, but Jesus is saying that your love and mind
is so important to him that he thinks heaven isn't complete without, isn't that absolutely
astonishing? That's like saying you have one of these masterful paintings done by a great artist,
and there are all kinds of colors in it. Each one of those little strokes is absolutely essential
for making the marvel of the entire picture, and so each one of us will be a little stroke of love
with different colors as well in heaven, and each one is very important. So he said,
"the love of the whole of heaven would not render me satisfied and content. If yours were not there,
united with it. More so, since that love, that's the love in heaven, is my own property, which no one
can take away from me, while the love of the pilgrim souls is like property that I'm in the act of
acquiring. And since my grace is part of me, and my being is most active, as it enters into hearts,
the pilgrim souls make traffic of love." Now, that traffic of love is this divine commerce,
which is illustrated in Genesis 28 with Jacob's ladder, and Jesus said that he was the fulfillment
of that in John 1.51. Okay, this commerce of love, that we love him and he loves us.
So his love for us is the source of all life, all grace, all beauty, everything, and our love
for him is a response. Just like you give life to a child, and you feed the child, and clothe the
child, and love the child, and medicate the child, and house the child, and do absolutely everything,
everything, and the child returns the love. The love is the completion of the circle.
So as my grace enters into the hearts of the pilgrim souls, it can make the traffic of love,
and this traffic expands the properties of my love. Now, the properties of my love means
expands the kingdom of God. And I feel such taste and pleasure that if it were missing,
I would remain embittered. Instead of the word taste, we would say satisfaction.
So write the word satisfaction there. I feel such satisfaction and pleasure that if it was missing,
I would remain embittered. That's why without your love, the love of all heaven would not render
me fully content. And you should know how to traffic well in my love. That's very important.
As a victim soul, she should learn how to use the love of Jesus well. Now, we need to learn to
traffic in God's love as well. And by that, I mean that we enter into him. We fuse ourselves
completely with him. We take his divine love. Once we have fused ourselves, we make it our own,
and we bathe all the souls in purgatory with his love so that they are released. We bathe all the
dying souls with his love so that they will surrender to him. And we bathe all souls past,
present and future with his love so that they will come to know and love him. And we need to make
the intention to do that permanently at every moment of every day, of every week, of every year.
You should know how to traffic well in my love for by loving me in everything you will render me
happy and content. Louisa says, "Who can say how amazed I was on hearing this and how many things
I understood about this love with my tongue is stammering and I'll have to leave it there." She
just is not able to actually say the words. So I want to give you August the 21st, 1901,
and I have a VIP on this one as well. As I was in my usual state, I found myself outside of myself,
and after going round and round in search of Jesus, I found the Queen Mother instead.
And oppressed and tired as I was, I said to her, my most sweet mother, I lost the way to find Jesus.
I don't know where else to go or what to do in order to find him again.
And while saying this, I was crying and she said to me, "My daughter, follow me and you will find
the way and Jesus." There's a very, very important piece of teaching from Blessed Mother. She knows
the way to find Jesus and she is our mother and she is our guide as well. And she's the one who
brings everybody to Jesus. Even more, Blessed Mother said, "I want to teach you the secret
of how you can always be with Jesus and live always content and happy even on this earth."
What you need to do is fix in your interior that there is only Jesus and yourself in the world
and nobody else and that he alone, you must please satisfy and love and from him alone
that you must expect to be loved in return and contented in everything. In other words,
that you turn completely into a he and I world and therefore we knock out all the extraneous
stuff that's driving everybody crazy today. And you knock out all of those terrible films that
people are watching in commentaries and everything else on the internet and the television that's
distracting people completely. And it's not leaving them enough inner space or inner piece to be able
to have this wonderful relationship with Jesus. Blessed Mother said, "If you are in this way with
Jesus, you will no longer be affected whether you are surrounded by scorn or praise, by relatives
or strangers, by friends or enemies. Jesus alone will be your all and all. He will be all your
contentment and Jesus alone will be enough for you in the place of everyone. My daughter, until
everything that exists down here that is on earth, disappears completely in the soul, one cannot find
true and perpetual contentment." Now, what she's saying here is that until we reach complete
detachment from the world, we cannot find God completely. We have a lot of work to do, haven't we?
Now, while she was saying this, Jesus came into our midst as though from within a flash.
After the way he appeared, after the resurrection as well, I took him and brought him with me and
I found myself inside of myself. Now, I'm going to leave it there for this time.